can we take a step in that direction of
autonomous vehicles
actually talking to the cto of waymo
tomorrow
and obviously i'm talking to elon again
in a couple weeks
what's your thoughts on autonomous
vehicles like where do we stand
well as a as a problem that has the
potential of revolutionizing the world
well you know i'm really excited about
that but
it's become much clearer that the
original way that i thought about it
most people thought about like you know
we have a self-driving car or not
is way too simple the the better way to
think about it is
there's a whole continuum of how much
driving and assisting the car can do i
noticed that you're right next here
to your next door to toyota research
that's a total
accident i love the tri folks but yeah
have you talked to gil pratt
uh yeah we're going to we're supposed to
talk it's
it's kind of hilarious so there's kind
of the op i think it's a good
counterpart to see what elon is doing um
and hopefully they can be frank in how
what they think about each other because
i've heard both of them talk about it
um but they're much more you know this
is an assistive a guardian angel that
watches over you is supposed to try to
do everything
i think there's some things like driving
on a highway you know from
l.a to phoenix where it's mostly good
weather straight roads
that's close to a solved problem let's
face it
in other situations you know driving
through the snow in boston
where the roads are kind of crazy and
most importantly you have to make a lot
of judgments about what the other driver
is going to do at these intersections
that
aren't really right angles and aren't
very well described it's more like game
theory
that's a much harder problem and
requires understanding human motivations
and um so there's a continuum there of
some places where the cars will
uh work very well and others where it
could
probably take decades what do you think
about the waymo
so you mentioned two companies that are
actually have cars on the road
there's the waymo approach that's more
like we're not going to release anything
until it's perfect and we're going to
be very strict about the streets that we
travel on but it
better be perfect yeah well
i'm smart enough to be humble and not
try to get between i
i know there's very bright people on
both sides of the argument i've talked
to them and they make convincing
arguments to me
about how careful they need to be and
the social acceptance
um some people thought that when the
first few people died
from self-driving cars that would shut
down the industry but it was more of a
blip actually and you know so that was
interesting um of course there's still a
concern that if
uh there could be setbacks if we do this
wrong
you know your listeners may be familiar
with the different levels of
self-driving you know level one two
three four
five i think andrewang has convinced me
that this idea of
really focusing on level four where you
only go in areas that are well mapped
rather than just going out in the wild
is the way things are going to evolve
but you can just keep expanding those
areas where you've mapped things really
well where you really understand them
and eventually all become kind of
interconnected and that could be a a
kind of another way of progressing
to make it more feasible over time
i mean that's kind of like the waymo
approach which is they uh they just now
released i think just like a day or two
ago
a public like anyone from the public
in the um and the
phoenix arizona to uh
you know you can get a ride in a way
more car with no person no driver
oh they've taken away the safety driver
oh yeah there's for a while now there's
been no safety driver
uh okay because i mean i've been
following that one in particular but i
thought it was kind of funny
about a year ago when they had the
safety driver then they added a second
safety driver because the first safety
driver would fall asleep
that's like i'm not sure they're going
the right direction with that no they
they've way more in particular done a
really good job with that they
they actually have a very interesting
infrastructure
of remote like observation
so they're not they're not controlling
the vehicles remotely but they're able
to
it's like a customer service that yeah
any time tune into the car
i i bet they can probably remotely
control it as well but that's officially
not the function
that they yeah i can see that being uh
really because
i think the thing that's proven harder
than maybe some of the early
people expected was there's a long tale
of weird exceptions
yeah so you can deal with 90 99 99.99
percent of the cases
but then there's something that just
never been seen before in the training
data
and humans you know more or less can
work around that although let me
be clear and note there are about 30 000
human fatalities
just in the united states and maybe a
million worldwide so they're
far from perfect but um i think people
have higher expectations of machines
they don't wouldn't tolerate
that level of death and
damage from a machine and so we have to
do a lot better at dealing with those
edge cases
and also the the tricky thing that if i
have a criticism for the weymouth folks
there is
such a huge focus on safety
where people don't talk enough about
creating products that people
that customers love like human beings
love using
you know it's very easy to create a
thing that's safe
at the extremes but then nobody wants to
get into it
yeah well back to elon i think one of
part of his genius was with the electric
cars before he came along
electric cars were all kind of
underpowered really light and they were
sort of wimpy cars
that you know weren't fun and the first
thing he did was
you know he made a roadster that went
zero to 60 faster than just about any
other car
and went the other end and i think that
was a really wise marketing move as well
as a rise
technology move yeah it's difficult to
figure out what
uh right marketing move is for ai
systems that's always been uh
i think it requires guts and risk taking
which is uh
which is what elon practices i mean to
to the chagrin of perhaps investors or
whatever but
guts and risk it also requires you know
rethinking what you're doing
i think way too many people are
unimaginative intellectually lazy
and when they take ai they basically say
what are we doing now
how can we make a machine do the same
thing maybe we'll save some costs we'll
have less labor
and yeah you know it's not necessarily
the worst thing in the world to do but
it's really not
leading to a quantum change in the way
you do things you know when
when jeff bezos said hey we're going to
use the internet to change how
bookstores work and we use technology
he didn't go and say okay let's let's
put a robot cashier where the human
cashier is and leave everything else
alone
that would have been a very lame way to
automate a bookstore he's like went from
soup to nuts let's just
rethink it we get rid of the physical
bookstore we have a warehouse we have
delivery we have people order on a
screen
and everything was reinvented and that's
been the story of these general purpose
technologies all through history
you